heldt
am dritten april 2017 besuchten
bundespräsident alexander van der bellen
und verteidigungsminister hans peter
oszko ziel das kommando schnelle
einsätze in der ferne in mautern an
mehreren stationen wurden wegen wirkung
des kommandos schnelle einsätze
vorgeführt ergaben dass die richtige
entscheidungen fallen mehr getroffen
dass wir in den verschiedensten
bereichen vorsorge spezielle trug man
fähigkeiten benötigen spezialisieren das
ist ein beispiel heute man hat durch
diese sieben zusammenführung sieben
verbände gesehen welche fähigkeiten hier
aufeinander abgestimmt werden und ich
glaube dass hier die mitarbeiter sehr
motiviert sind einen hohen grad an
professionalität haben und der auch eine
folge ich hab das mit größtem interesse
gehört und gesehen was alles gemacht
wird und was gemacht werden kann von den
abc einsetzen die sanität und die
pioniere natürlich bis hin zum
tatsächlichen gefecht einsatz den wir
simuliert haben sonst mit sagen sehr
interessant hochachtung vor den
fähigkeiten und leistungen des
bundesheers